Queen Bee is finally revealing her  secret to bouncing back after babies  good morning wait 175 long way to go  yeah that's B on a scale showing her  number this very real moment marked the  start of her post twins pre Coachella  comeback power the woman that I felt  like my body was so how did she get her  body back before hitting the stage by  following a 22 day plant-based program  but in true V style she doubled up doing  the strict diet for 44 days no amount of  exercise in the world can undo the  effects of a poor diet no amount of  exercise be secret weapon this guy Marco  Borges a celebrity trainer created the  22 days nutrition diet and also helped B  get in shape for her 2016 formation tour  his meals include beans vegetables whole  grains and nuts and seeds the big no-no  processed foods you start to lose weight  your skin starts to get tighter you  start to sleep better you start to have  a better mood  [Music]  you